hallo mein name ist luca und meine
lieben freunde ich habe einst frei
bekommen und das ist nicht gut erst mal
alle leute die sich mit der kompletten
youtube mädchen nicht auskennen ein
streik ist so eine art anzeige von
youtube an den creator also dem fall
mich weil der creator irgendwas gesagt
was ich aber sagen dürfen weil irgendwas
gezeigt haben was mich heute zeigen
dürfen oder weil er gegen die community
richtlinie verstoßen hatte
ich anscheinend ich habe vor einer woche
ein video auf meinem 2 kanal hochgeladen
in dem ich auf jungs reagiert habe die
mehr hamburger innenstadt wenn du hast
gespielt haben das ist so eine challenge
ich habe darauf reagiere ich aber gesagt
dass ich eigentlich ganz money fand und
dann wurde mein video nach einer woche
direkt wieder gesperrt weil youtube sich
dachte mensch da hat er gegen die
community richtlinien verstoßen nur mal
kurz zur info das video auf dass sich
reagiert habe ist noch online
und das auch schon seit insgesamt sechs
jahren das heißt weil ich eine community
richtigen den verstoß erhalten habe dass
es sich wirklich bei meinem video meinen
großen fehler handelte weil ich auch
schon mal die situation hatte dass ich
auf ein video reagiert habe dann habe
ich einen streit bekommen und dachte
okay um was geht und das rad wieder auf
das ich erlebt habe hat auch ein strike
bekommen du musst ja okay ist nicht mein
fehler ich habe auf reagiert das heißt
wenn ihnen die mitschuld bleibt weil ich
alles irgendwo verstehen aber jetzt weiß
es wirklich nicht in die begründung von
youtube ist schutz von kindern
[Musik]
habe ich jetzt kinder hat erklärte mein
video oder wie ich habe damit bei jedem
selbstverständlich beschwerde eingelegt
und habe gesagt ich weiß nicht was ich
falsch gemacht haben soll erklären sie
doch bitte die wurde abgelehnt ich habe
dann bei unserem youtube ansprechpartner
nachgehakt und gefragt worum geht's sagt
mir doch zumindest eine stelle im video
können wir leider nichts machen
ja hab ich dann gedacht bevor ich jetzt
und du bist wieder auf brenner hochladen
mache ich doch ne story das geht ja
mittlerweile auf youtube auf dem 2 von
wegen leute tschuldigung gekommen der
woche keine videos gratis bekommen geht
nicht weil ich ja in streit bekommen
habt dann dachte ich mir mensch dann
schreibe ich zumindest eine info auf
meine 2 kanal in den community care
breiter so dass ein kleiner beitrag bei
euch auf eurer seite erscheint um den
hessenpokal hier kommt der woche keine
videos haben strake com geht auch nicht
weil ich in strike bekommen aber ich
kann mich weder das video noch angucken
noch habe ich eine stelle bekommen von
youtube noch kritischer transparente
antwort von denen das wissen wir schon
und hat deswegen sogar extra die
plattform gewechselt jetzt von youtube
auftritt gegangen weil jeder weiß dass
youtube ansprechpartner zumindest bei
uns in deutschland echt nicht so hilft
helfen können denn probleme da sind also
weder weiß nicht um was es genau geht
noch kann ich mir das noch mal angucken
noch kann ich vernünftig eine beschwerde
einlegen noch kann mir irgendjemand
wirklich sagen um was ist konkret geht
und ich kann auch niemandem darüber
informieren denn wenn ich nur diesen
zweikanal hätte und sonst keine andere
reichweite auf der plattform wüsstet ihr
es einfach nicht damals wollte ich eine
woche einfach weggewesen oder 30 tage
was als nächstes kommen wenn ich jetzt
noch mal hingefahren und kriegen sollte
oder keine lange rede kurzer sinn das
ist nur ganz kurz hin von euch am
sonntag die 2002 kanal ich habe viele
nachricht bekommen warum dort nicht mehr
day hochgeladen wurde morgen geht es
weiter mit einem neuen video auf dem
hauptkanal ich will jetzt auch nicht
weiter auslassen ist einfach nur blöd
ich kann es verstehen wenn ich ein tor
gemacht habe dann weiß mich darauf hin
was ich genau gemacht haben soll aber
ich hier kinder immer geschützt ich weiß
nicht was das jetzt irgendwie
ganz kurze info dieses video geht auch
ein paar tagen wieder aufladen aber es
geht am sonntag weiter auf den 2